now she just hit Oak it's a shocking
scene in Oklahoma when a woman steals a
truck for a joy ride takes police on a
chase and then purposely crashes into a
cruiser but that's not all when asked to
turn herself in she pulls up her shirt
and flashes officers get on your stomach
right now my stomach I'm going let
sleep this all happened in Edmund
Oklahoma just outside of Oklahoma City
it was about 6:00 in the morning on
January 2nd when a maintenance employee
for a local school was warming up his
truck that's when a woman hopped inside
and drove off body camera video shows
multiple officers on her
tail now we're going into Dan fig Studio
there are no phones connected connect
the phone and try
again please
not
[Music]
Park
traffic we're still doing North going on
Kelly
light light traffic she just blew
light we're coming to aop at the same
res
106 now we're pulling into dance maker
Studio she's not stopping she's going
through the parking lot now we're
approaching ATT parking
lot Northbound on
Kelly dash camera video captures this
too and shows officers catch up with a
woman who has pulled the truck onto a
lawn instead of putting the car into
park she pushes on the gas slamming
right into a squad
car we're coming to a stop at the same
Residence at
106 at
she's now she just hit Oak here's body
camera video from the officer whose car
she crashed into you can hear the moment
of
impact let me see your hands let me see
your
hands another officer radios in the
situation as it's happening before
jumping out of her Squad with a stun gun
at the ready she's now she just hit
Oak get out of the vehicle both officers
call for the woman to get out of the
truck and put her hands up she ignores
this and instead screams for the
officers to shoot her let me see your
hands let me see your hands get out of
the car right now get out of the
car get out of the car let me see your
hands get on your stomach get on your
stomach right now instead of getting on
her stomach the woman pulls up her shirt
my stomach I'm going let
sleep body camera video shows these same
moments from the other responding
officer
[Music]
perspective let me your get out of the
car right now get out of the car
get out of the let me see
[Music]
your a third camera recording this time
a dash camera video captures the woman
exposing herself proving there's no
question about it she did Flash the
officers on your stach right now come
on just after the woman pulls up her
shirt both officers shoot off their stun
guns up next there's a struggle as
officers try to put the woman into
handcuffs no give me your
hand put your hands behind your
back at one point the suspect starts to
say you'll have to kill before trailing
off as the struggle continues she says
kill them multiple times give me your
hand you have to kill quit your put your
hands behind your back can't I
got you got
her
help help kill
them help me my gun
[Music]
all right we're good okay let's powder
down make sure she does have any weapons
I got a
gun baby kill
[Music]
them all right we're going to get back
to this body cam in a second but I want
to take a minute to talk about something
else that happens all the time workplace
injuries if you get hurt at your job
whether it's a slip fall a mechanical
failure negligence of your co-workers
something hits you you're going to need
a trusted law firm in your corner enter
Pon Le hockey Giordano a firm that is a
heavyweight in the industry that wins
all different kinds of injury cases yes
workplace but also accidents Social
Security Disability injuries they have a
track record of recovering over $1
billion dollar for their clients and
they have won over a 100,000 cases they
have 250 years of combined experience
how amazing is that so you can check out
ponle hockey Giordano at ponle
hockey.com
ELC bodycam or you can pick up the phone
and call them at 833 669 4043 all right
let's get back to the body cam finally
officers get her in handcuffs but she
keeps on screaming we got her in
handcuffs anything uh we did taser what
are yall
doing make sure she don't have anything
boots don't hurt me
okay that hurt roll her to her
side ma' I'm going to pull your pants up
hey we're trying to help
you the woman eventually tells officers
her name is Stephanie and claims to have
suffered a gunshot wound officers assure
her it was just a taser and that she
hasn't been shot even still she puts up
a fight during a pat down what's your
name what's your name Bethany Bethany
what's going on
tonight y have water I smell it what you
been using
tonight what is that
stuff it's water y'all put it under my
house I got a
gun let's roll her up all right Bethany
we're going to roll you up
Stephanie Stephanie stand up stand up
tuck your leg I have a gunot from you
you haven't been shot you were tased no
from the other
day what other day oh when you me
gut
cop yeah not good whose car is this
okay me in
it I got a
gun let me double check her boots s your
feet in a white St oh he's raping oh
she don't do you have anything illegal
on you no I know after loading the
suspect into a squad car she's later
Taken back out to be checked out out by
paramedics why he being so rough on
me what's your
name Stephanie spell it for me I don't
know how they've been watering me
Stephanie what's your last
name I don't know Mitchell
Mitchell what is your date of birth
would you
quit Stephanie what's your date of
birth oh
my
stach she was in a Pursuit and then she
got tased and yeah at the same time
officers on the scene recap what
happened how'd she hit your car just
straight into the side yeah my car was
sitting exactly where it was and she
just ramed it straight
on let's go ahead and get the cars
on you good
yeah as she's being wheeled away the
suspect yells one last profanity at
First
Responders
well that's rude can't say that she now
faces charges of unauthorized use of a
vehicle attempting to elude and assault
and battery of a police officer
reporting for long crime I'm Sierra
Gillespie